je suis né à orléans et je mets racines
en corse a eu tchane dans la montagne
mes grands-parents des fonctionnaires et
des ouvriers devenus patrons grâce à
l'école j'ai quatre enfants et chaque
matin je pense à leur avenir je ne suis
pas le plus connu mais je suis celui qui
vous comprends je m'appelle philippe
juvin je suis médecin et toute ma vie je
travaillais avec des personnes dévouées
au service des autres des femmes et des
hommes engagés qui protège et duke swan
servent et aide nos compatriotes leur
tâche est immense car la souffrance
s'amplifie chaque jour
parallèlement ma vie de médecin je suis
maire depuis vingt ans j'ai été député
européen pendant dix ans j'ai même été
militaire en afghanistan contre les
talibans toutes ces expériences je veux
les mettre au service de notre pays ça
fait 40 ans que la france est malade
comme médecin et quand mr je vois que
nous sommes devenus plus pauvres que nos
voisins que nos services publics ferment
que l'état est de plus en plus directif
et de moins en moins efficace nous ne
sommes plus protégé la violence explose
partout même notre ère et notre
alimentation se dégrade et pendant ce
temps là que font les hommes politiques
ils commentent ils proposent toujours
les mêmes vieilles recettes
pour eux qu'ils seront toujours à l'abri
la politique c'est d'abord une rente
cela assez dur et nous devons tout
changer
il est temps de reprendre le contrôle
sur cette bureaucratie qui nous étouffe
sur ses décisions qui se prennent tout à
paris sur ce mépris pour tous ceux qui
ne viennent pas de la bonne école ou du
bon quartier c'est pour apporter des
solutions que je suis candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
je mettrai fin au désordre je redonnerai
à la france sa place dans le monde je
simplifierait toute cette norme et
patras qui nous asphyxie jeu
moderniserait les services publics je
reconstruirai notre recherche et notre
industrie qui nous ont bradé
j'accélérais la transition écologique et
j'améliorais notre alimentation je
lutterai contre l'ignorance et je
réanimera notre école je ferai en sorte
que chaque français est un médecin pour
se soigner et un toit pour s'abriter
j'aiderai d'abord ceux qui veulent s'en
sortir j'aurais considéré les français
je laisserais s'épanouir les talents de
chacun je ferai confiance aux élus
locaux aux chercheurs aux entrepreneurs
aux bénévoles aux agriculteurs à tous
ceux qui se lèvent tôt à tous ceux qui
nous protège à tous ceux qui nous éduque
et à tous ceux qui sont sur le terrain
le moment est venu il est temps de
reprendre le contrôle
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle philippe g20
cherche philippe à toi
et bien mes amis
les amis tout d'abord je dois remercier
la présidente du conseil national ainsi
que président de notre parti d'avoir du
goût parce que nous sommes réunis
dans le plus gros départements de france
le département des hauts-de-seine dont
j'ai l'honneur d'être le président de la
fédération
et c'est un département qui aiment la
politique voyez vous
c'est le département de charles pasqua
c'est le département de patrick
devedjian
et c'est le département de nicolas
sarkozy
alors oui je vous le dis vous êtes tous
ici chez vous dans ce département on
aime la politique
on aime aussi la famille je n'ai jamais
quitter notre famille politique et dieu
sait que les temps ces dernières années
ne furent pas facile mais j'ai toujours
considéré qu'il fallait avoir une
colonne vertébrale et parmi cette
colonne vertébrale il y avait
l'appartenance à ma famille politique
depuis quelques années et
particulièrement ces deux dernières
années à quoi assistons nous
nous assistons
un spectacle de france qui tombe
avec des français qui ne peuvent plus se
soigner
une école qui ne remplit plus son rôle
d'ascenseur social une dette qui explose
des français individuellement plus
pauvre qu'il n'était il ya quelques
années et à côté qu'est ce qu'on voit on
voit des hommes politiques qui font du
commentaire un gouvernement qui
commentent qui a l'impression de n'être
pas au courant des choses on a entendu
monsieur véran ya trois jours qui
regardant les 20% de lits 1 disponible
dans les hôpitaux de france nous
expliquait naïvement nous allons étudier
essayer de comprendre pourquoi ce sont
des gens qui ne sont pas dans la vie
politique vous l'êtes vous voyez les
choses et vous vous avez compris que la
france avait besoin d'une potion non pas
une potion magique mais une potion qui
fasse que demain nous retrouvions la
france que nous étions auparavant les
hommes politiques ils commentent ce
gouvernement ne fait que commenter et
quand il ne commande pas il est sûr de
lui il est content de lui et je ne me
souviens ce ministre qui expliquait à
nos voisins suisses
suisse comment il fallait gérer un
budget ça me rappelle cette discussion
entre l'ambassadeur
l'ambassadeur de suisse et il ya
l'ambassadeur de france alors
l'ambassadeur de france demande à
l'ambassadeur de suisse mais pourquoi
avez-vous une ministère de la marine et
l'ambassadeur de susurrer pour vous avez
bien ministère des finances
nous notre sujet désormais est assez
simple c'est que devant cette france qui
tombe
de francs cette classe politique
incapable d'apporter des réponses ce
gouvernement sans cesse content de lui
qui fait du commentaire et valeo l'a
très bien dit tout à l'heure nous
débattons avec des contradicteurs de
lundi
le lendemain mardi le président de la
république sur la même durée de temps
individuel fait sa déclaration en
expliquant tout va bien madame la
marquise c'est ça la différence devises
entre eux et nous on nous demandait tout
à l'heure de savoir pourquoi finalement
emmanuel macron nous en étiez lieu où
nous en étions loin nous en sommes loin
parce que nous nous avons compris que la
france avait été grande et voulait de
nouveau l'être je crois moi qu'il est
important que nous les candidats à cette
primaire eh bien nous ayons non pas un
catalogue de mesures à vous donner
mais une vision de la france
cette vision de la france
selon moi elle à quatre pans le premier
dépend c'est que nous devons mettre fin
au désordre
la fin du désordre et la condition
absolue de la réussite de la suite
mettre fin au désordre de l'immigration
pour faire simple l'immigration n'est
pas un droit et la france a le droit de
décider qui vient sont sept sur son
territoire cette question complexe nous
la traiterons avec fermeté et nous la
traiterons avec humanité on ne va pas
faire caricaturer sur l'immigration mais
on ne peut pas ne pas nous laisser dire
que oui la france a le droit de choisir
qui vient sur son territoire et la
question de l'identité qui est derrière
moi l'identité nationale je veux qu'on
comprenne que ce n'est pas une arme
contre ceux qui viennent s'installer en
france l'idée date l'identité nationale
au contraire c'est un cadeau qu'on fait
à ce qui arrive quand vous décidez
devenir français quand vous décidez de
venir sur notre territoire vous devenez
les gardiens d'une vieille histoire dont
vous devez être fier et je ne veux pas
que celui qui arrive chez nous nous
explique que tout ce que nous avons fait
depuis des siècles ne vaut pas et
détestable la france moi j'en suis fier
je suis fière de son histoire je suis
fier de ses us et coutumes l'immigration
elle vient en france et quand elle vient
eh bien elle doit s'intégrer elle doit
s'assimiler elle doit respecter les us
elle doit respecter nos coutumes elle
doit respecter nos lois mais elle doit
respecter plus trop content que ça elle
doit respecter ce que nous sommes et ce
que nous avons construit le fameux legs
indivis d'ernest renan la fin du
désordre c'est la sécurité bien entendu
et pour faire court que voulons nous
nous voguons que la peur change de camp
charles pasqua avait dit un jour que il
fallait terroriser les terroristes
et bien c'est ça on y revient toujours
ce n'est pas un seul pas on est
terroriste que nous voulons terroriser
nous voulons que la peur change de camp
et que les voyous et les petites
racailles qui pourrissent la vie de nos
agents se disent oui le droit n'est pas
pour nous nous ne pouvons pas nous
préoccuper de la manière dont nous
allons être défendus nous devons savoir
que nous serons punis la certitude de la
peine mes amis est plus importante que
la sévérité de celle ci il ya toujours
après une affaire de faits divers un
sous secrétaires d'état ou un sous
ministre qui se croient plus intelligent
qu'un autre et qui propose une nouvelle
loi mais nous n'en voulons pas de
nouvelle loi nous voulons simplement que
le code pénal soit ouvert soit lui soit
appliquée faisons déjà cela et vous
verrez la france ira mieux l'immigration
la sécurité et puis l'ordre c'est aussi
les services publics moi je crois en la
droite des services publics pourquoi
parce que les services publics c'est
d'abord la chance que chacun soit
traitée pareillement sur le territoire
et quand les services publics
disparaissent il y en a d'autres qui les
remplacent et dans certains quartiers ce
sont des pseudos imams qui remplace les
services publics comprenez que le
séparatisme commence là où les services
publics disparaissent je pense que c'est
une erreur de vouloir faire porter aux
services publics une potion qui pourrait
les affaiblir comment voulez vous qu
alors que nous sortons d'une crise
démentent
aujourd'hui vingt mille 20 % des lits
d'hospitalisation sont fermés et qu'on
ne peut pas tous vous soigner c'est ça
la réalité de tous les jours qu'on
prenait 2 il n'y a pas suffisamment de
policiers n'y a pas suffisamment de juge
comment voulez-vous que à ce moment là
nous décidions d'affaiblir et de
diminuer les services publics je vous le
dis je ne serai pas le candidat qui dans
les premières années diminuera le nombre
de fonctionnaires parce que nous en
avons besoin
les services publics c'est une deuxième
chose
c'est la capacité d'être un pays
prospère ne vous faites aucune illusion
sans service public qui fonctionne
il n'y a pas de possibilité de france
prospère quand vous avez 15 % des
enfants qui savent pas lire et écrire en
sixième y a aucune chance que 20 ans
plus tard il y en ait un qui fabrique un
vaccin ou construisent une centrale
nucléaire tout commence à l'école tout
commence dans des services publics
modernes et efficaces je veux rendre les
services publics modernes efficaces
premier pan de l'action politique on met
fin aux déserts deuxième temps on donne
de la liberté aux français il faut faire
confiance aux entrepreneurs qu'ils
entreprennent aux chercheurs qui
cherchent aux enseignants en leur
donnant une autonomie à toutes celles et
ceux qui veulent exprimer leurs
potentialités nous devons être la droite
qui fait confiance aux individus on se
posait la question de savoir pourquoi
certains services publics fonctionnaient
mieux qu'un autre et vous avez nous
avons été plusieurs à citer cet exemple
extraordinaire xavier de l'hôpital de
valenciennes pourquoi ça marche à
l'hôpital de valenciennes parce qu'on a
fait confiance aux fonctionnaires at-on
changer ce statut de la fonction
publique non at on abolit le code des
marchés publics si compliqué non on a
fait confiance
aux médecins et aux infirmières qui
travaillent dans cet hôpital
l'hôpital était en déficit et les en
excédent il faisait de la mauvaise
médecine fait excellentes médecine il y
avait des postes vacants tous les postes
sont pourvus c'est ça le secret des
choses faites confiance aux individus et
les individus vous rendront les grandes
révolutions des sociétés viennent du
fait que les individus ont pris le
pouvoir ne croyez pas cette fable que
l'état sait tout et les tarés pour ça
tout l'état quand il sort du régalien ma
première vision de la société dont que
je viens de vous décrire il se trompe
souvent et il n'est plus la solution il
est souvent le problème parce qu'il
complexifie les sujets faisons confiance
au maire dans leur commune plutôt
qu'avoir à leur expliquer ce qu'il
fallait faire et moi je me souviens en
tant que maire de ce coup de fil du
préfet que nous avions le lendemain de
l'annoncé officielle faite par le
premier ministre où le président sur les
menaces les mesures prises dans
l'épidémie nous étions informés après
tout le monde nous les maires alors que
c'est nous le président du sénat l'a dit
qui sommes la colonne vertébrale de la
république et il n'y aurait pas eu les
maires dans le gilet jaune il y aurait
plus de république nous sommes la
colonne vertébrale et moi je renforcerai
le pouvoir des élus locaux
fin du désordre beaucoup de liberté
donnée aux individus et enfin inventons
un modèle de prospérité la prospérité
nous avons besoin de réenrichir le pays
il ne sert à rien promettre qu'on va
redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat si on
n'a pas créé voilà l'état de la richesse
du pays et quand vous avez une petite
richesses du pays comment voulez-vous
vous redistribuez ce qui est en réalité
de la pénurie moi je veux augmenter la
richesse du pays j'ai pas de baguette
magique mais je vous dire une chose je
sais que pour redistribuer de la
richesse d'abord il faut l'avoir
produite et cette richesse comment
allons-nous la reproduire la réforme des
impôts de production qui sont les impôts
les plus idiots qui oblige celui qui
ouvre une entreprise à payer des impôts
alors même qu'il a eu avant même qu'il
est son premier client 109 milliards
d'impôts que payent des entreprises
françaises comprenez une chose c'est que
les entreprises françaises payent à
elles seules des impôts de production en
quantité identique à tous les impôts de
production payés par les 23 par 23 pays
de l'union allemagne comprise c'est
comme si vous donniez un sac à dos plein
de pierres à des entreprises françaises
leur disant faut maintenant que tu court
aussi vite que l'allemand le polonais ou
belge ce n'est pas possible libérons les
entreprises baisse massive 35 milliards
d impôt de production c'est un impôt qui
tuent l'impôt
la question des retraites
nous avons un système de retraite qui
appauvrit celui qui paye qui n'enrichit
pas celui qui reçoit et qui a prouvé le
pays je veux passer partiellement un
système de capitalisation collective
avec un système de capitalisation
collectif on donne les moyens aux pays
de préparer l'avenir pourquoi d'autres y
arrivent et que nous n'y arrivons pas il
nous manque ces outils là enfin
l'enrichissement du pays c'est un
enrichissement intellectuel
15% vous les jeudis d'enfants qui savent
pas lire écrire comment voulez vous un
instant que le pays redevienne prospère
il ya 25 ans quand vous sortiez de
l'école vous aviez dans votre bagage 25
ans de vie professionnelle pendant 25
ans vous saviez que vous pouviez vivre
avec ce qu'on avait ce que vous aviez un
prix et vous allez y et tenir 25 ans
dans votre vie professionnelle
aujourd'hui quand vous sortez de l'école
vous en avez pour cinq ans
l'enseignement c'est l'enseignement
initial et c'est leur segment continue
la france a besoin en permanence de se
former nous devons comprendre cela je
souhaite par exemple que des diplômes
puisse être délivrés par des entreprises
j'étais à morlaix il ya quelques
semaines il ya quelques semaines le chef
d'entreprise qui fabrique des chaudières
à gaz m'expliquer que les jeunes ouvrier
soudeur qui sortent de l'école n'ont
jamais fait soudure avec les appareils
qu'ils utilisent mais avec des appareils
qui ne sont plus utilisés depuis dix ans
nous devons réformer notre système de
formation faire en sorte qu'ils soient
adaptés au monde économique c'est
fondamental sans cela nous ne créerons
pas de richesse 1
vous avez droit l'applaudir
un état qui fonctionne sur le régalien
efficace de beaucoup de liberté la
confiance en réalité donner aux
individus trois de l'enrichissement
collectif intellectuelle et économique 4
je veux des institutions représentatives
qui fonctionne vous allez me dire c'est
pas très original bah ça le devient
parce que quand vous demandez un comité
théodule tirés au sort ce qu'ils pensent
de la vaccination un autre encore plus
tirés au sort quoique sur le climat vous
vous dites à quoi sert la représentation
nationale à quoi servent les conseils
municipaux puisque on est obligé en
permanence de deux demandes et la vie à
des gens qui n'y connaissent rien qui
sont tirés au sort même si parfois je
m'interroge sur les effets du tirage au
sort quand je vois que sur la convention
citoyenne pour le climat personne
n'était pour le nucléaire c'est le seul
endroit en france où j'ai découvert des
gens qui parlent du climat mais qui
jamais ne parle de nucléaire
alors voilà mes amis
j'ai été député européen disant ça a été
un grand honneur pas fait mon parti
politique est là bas espagne nadine
quand on parle on a le droit 60 secondes
alors quand on se libère et qu'on est
dans les hautes fagnes en france on
parle plus longtemps je vais conclure
sur cette anecdote que j'ai raconté
durant à des débats c'était quand
j'étais député européen je me souviens
du matin où il y avait un pays qui
s'appelait la grèce qui avait plus de
médecins
comme nous aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient
des fonctionnaires qui étaient mal payés
ou pas payé c'est nous en réalité
puisque nous payons les fonctionnaires à
crédit en tirant des traites sur
l'avenir bref y avait un pays qui
s'appelait la grèce et qui est
aujourd'hui le pays qui s'appelle la
france ce pays qui s'appelait la grèce
se réveille un matin et le port du pirée
le port historique de périclès et vendu
à les chinois moi je ne veux pas me
réveiller demain et apprendre que les
centrales nucléaires et apprendre que le
mont saint michel
et apprendre que nos tgv ont été vendus
à des chinois à des américains par le
fmi par la banque centrale européenne ou
que sais-je il ya une chose que vous
devez avoir en tête c'est qu'au fond le
plus important dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est la chose suivante
voulez vous que nous existions toujours
il est certain que quand un pays tombe
comme un pays tombe aujourd'hui comme
nous tombons collectivement il ya
forcément un modèle qui se succèdent
modèle passé et qui est ruiné nous avons
un modèle qui tombe et qui disparaît le
futur modèle de prospérité il existera
forcément la seule question est de
savoir qui va le définir voulez-vous que
nous le défi nition nous français où
voulez vous le voir imposer comme les
grecs selon vu imposé il ya dix ans par
d'autres en 1944 quand les américains
débarquent en normandie il débarque avec
une monnaie
cette monnaie elle est imprimée elle
doit avoir cours sur le territoire
national le général de gaulle s'y oppose
et il dit pas question pourquoi le
général de gaulle at il la force de
s'opposer à cette monnaie a mené par les
amériques apportées par les américains
pour une raison très simple c'est que
depuis deux ans le gouvernement d'alger
a travaillé et le gouvernement d'alger a
mis au point un projet de société ils se
sont dit les femmes et les hommes de là
bas non nous n'allons pas reprendre le
projet de développement économique et
social de mode de vie d'avant la guerre
nous devons inventer un nouveau projet
de prospérité mais c'est justement parce
que les françaises sont unis à ce moment
là et on définit eux mêmes le modèle de
prospérité qu'ils sont assez fort pour
l'imposer moi ce que je vous propose
c'est que nous soyons capables ensemble
de d'imposer à ceux qui veulent nous
imposer de l'extérieur notre propre
modèle de prospérité père fait dans son
livre c'était de gaulle raconte cette
anecdote
mon général de monti le général de
gaulle croyez vous que la france
existera toujours
et le général de gaulle ne répond pas
tout de suite ce qui signifie que la
question n'est pas évidente au bout de
quelques secondes du général de gaulle
répond probablement
à condition qu'elles le veuillent je
vous propose mesdames et messieurs
qu'ensemble nous voulions vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
mais avec six mètres s'échappaient alors
une première question je voudrais
revenir sur un sujet que tu a abordé
rapidement c'est celui des communes tu
es mère tu l'a rappelé dans sa très
riche expérience tu es maire de la
garenne colombes et je voudrais en
profiter pour
rappeler à quel point les communes ont
été depuis une dizaine d'années malmenés
je pense que c'est une petite révolution
dont on n'a pas encore fini de mesurer
les conséquences on les a privées
d'autonomie financière on leur a retiré
des compétences emmanuel macron les à
mépriser en considérant que les mères
étaient une association de lobby je
crois et il est il a essayé de les
instrumentaliser
tout récemment encore avec l'élection du
président de la mf en succession de
françois baroin donc on voit bien que
dans le même temps ces communes s'y
attaquer si fragilisés et qui sont
pourtant comme le dit le président
larcher la petite république dans la
grande et bien elles ont elles se sont
montrées absolument indispensable au
moment de la gestion de la crise et dans
tous les baromètres d'opinion vous le
savez le maire demeure l'élu le plus
proche de la population le mieux aimé de
tous ça veut dire quelque chose en plus
les communes nous rattache à notre
histoire profonde les communes sont les
héritières des paroisses donc tout ça
participe de l'identité de notre pays
alors la question serait de poser mon
cher philippe est la suivante tu as dit
je veux redonner du pouvoir où je veux
donner davantage de pouvoirs aux
communes dans un paysage territorial
tellement compliqué ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le mille feuille territorial
comment vois-tu les choses y at il des
évolutions tu voudrais porter et
notamment parce que j'aurais pu aussi te
poser cette question en matière de santé
puisque dans tous les questionnaires
qu'on livre aux français la question de
l'accès aux soins est une question
absolument fondamental et vous avez été
plusieurs à dire à quel point c'était un
sujet majeur auquel il fallait apporter
des réponses alors voilà deux questions
en une mais elles sont liées dans la
mesure où les mères déploie aussi
beaucoup d'énergie pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins dans leur commune
j'ai été élu maire il ya 20 ans ce beau
département des hauts-de-seine vous avez
compris
et
il y avait un temps je me présente je
fais le tour des des mers et puis je me
présente et où ces jeux débarquent des
buts et patrick devedjian à l'époque ne
reçoit me dis il ya beaucoup trop de
strates administratives
à cela il y avait la commune le
département et la région
vingt ans plus tard il y en a cinq et
puis des années on a multiplié les lois
de décentralisation
qui sont en réalité des lois de
recentralisation où on a retiré aux
communes du pouvoir en prétendant leur
randonnée il ya une sorte d' ailleurs d'
abus de langage que vous observerez on a
remplacé le mot commune parlement bloc
communal ce qui est une meilleure
manière habile en fait de déshabiller
les maires moi je crois que le demi
million conseillers municipaux de france
c'est un demi million de gens qui sont
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 tous les
jours de l'année à disposition de leurs
populations moi je ne veux plus qu'on
supprime les communes pendant des années
on a dit il faut faire comme l'allemagne
regrouper les communes c'est une erreur
le maire et les conseillers municipaux
mes amis ce sont les seules relations
des gens qui n'ont pas de relations
vous avez tous des relations
donc je veux mettre fin ou disparition
des communes évidemment les
intercommunalités sont indispensables
mais je souhaite qu'elle soit basée sur
la bi libre le libre choix des communes
que non seulement les intercommunalités
mais communes choisissent ou pas d'y
aller mais je vais aggraver mon cas
choisissent librement les compétences
qu'elles veulent tit m on ne peut plus
avoir de tir comme unité qui nous noie
donc oui je veux redonner du pouvoir aux
communes c'est très important sur les
déserts médicaux bah écoutez je
trouve plus un médecin généraliste
essayer de trouver un spécialiste
essayer de trouver un psychiatre et s'il
trouvait un gynécologue essayer de
trouver un psychiatre pour enfants mali
maladie mentale de l'enfant qu'elle a
plus ça n'existe plus alors c'est pas
qui en a plus il y en a pas suffisamment
moi ma proposition est très simple tout
ce qu'on a fait jusqu'ici on a essayé en
fait de gérer la pénurie qui n'a pas
suffisamment ma proposition première
c'est dès l'année prochaine je double le
nombre d'étudiants en médecine en
deuxième année de médecine il y en a
cent dans une faculté qui doivent passer
il y en aura 200 dès septembre prochain
c'est vrai ça aura des effets dans dix
ans mais depuis le temps qu'on dit dans
dix ans on l'aurait fait il ya dix ans
le problème c'est qu'on commencerait est
réglé deuxièmement je multiplie par deux
le nombre d'infirmières et
d'aides-soignantes fort mais pourquoi
les infirmières parce que je veux aussi
m'appuyer sur les infirmières aux villes
vous avez une maladie chronique un
diabète par exemple ou une hypertension
artérielle deux fois par an vous allez
voir votre généraliste pour qu'ils vous
prennent la tension il vous pose
quelques questions il vous renouvelle
ordonnance et bien c'est du temps qui
pourrait être en réalité passé par une
infirmière spécialisée qui ferait un an
d'étude dans cette pathologie là et
qu'il libérerait du temps à votre
généraliste enfin troisième mesure mais
j'en ai bien d'autres mais le temps est
limité c'est que chaque année
3600 jeunes généralistes arrivent sur le
marché du travail ma proposition est
très simple il ya trois ans nous dans
les hôpitaux je travaille dans un
hôpital qui est situé à proximité de
cette ce centre ce centre des congrès
l'hôpital européen georges pompidou nous
avons les mêmes difficultés de
recrutement les hôpitaux et bien on a
créé ce qu'on appelle les docteurs
juniors c'est à dire toutes les
spécialités sauf les généralistes c'est
très important on leur demande de faire
leurs dernières années d'internât alors
qu'ils sont docteurs en médecine très
important dans nos services comme ça il
parfait il part fait leur formation et
il nous aide à faire fonctionner le
service to cash back pour la garde du 25
décembre suis très content qu'un docteur
junior dans le service eh bien nous
allons faire pareil je vais faire pareil
avec les médecins généralistes y font un
nom de plus d'internât un nom de docteur
junior cette année docteur juniors ils
ne passeront pas dans les hôpitaux mais
il les passeront dans vos maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaires et regardez le
ratio
3600 généralistes tous les ans qui
sortent
il ya 1600 premier lui sans pardon
généralise qui sortent il ya 1600 maison
médicale en france je garantis donc à
partir du 1er novembre prochain puisque
l'année universitaire se finit en
novembre médecine que dans chaque maison
pluridisciplinaire
de france vous aurez deux médecins qui
viendront pendant un an était votre
population il a soigné au bout d'un an
et s'installeront où ils voudront et un
an plus tard d'autres de la génération
souvient arriveront c'est comme ça que
je commencerai à régler le problème dès
qu'elle est désert des déserts médicaux
cher philippe je voulais interroger sur
notre démocratie notre démocratie est
malade et ce qui fera sûrement la force
de notre famille politique et de notre
candidate ou candidat demain sera d'être
lucide sur l'état de santé notre
démocratie d'abord c'est cette montée
inexorable de l'abstention le décrochage
quasi systématique des moins de 30 ans
lorsqu'il s'agit de se mobiliser pour
les élections personne nulle part et pas
en particulier les héritiers du général
de gaulle ne peuvent se réjouir de cette
idée du décrochage démocratique d'une
partie de nos concitoyens notre
démocratie va mal parce qu emmanuel
macron a contribué à l'abîmé
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
sont plus d'une centaine d'ordonnancé
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
et qui n'ont pas été contrôlés comme
elle le devrait par l'action du
parlement notre démocratie elle est
malade tu l'as dis parce que ce
dirigisme installé par emmanuel macron
qui a consisté à faire sauter toutes les
strates de notre société tous les corps
de la société qui représentait notre
démocratie il a voulu les balayer d'un
revers de la main nous sommes les
héritiers de la vème république il est
donc sûrement plus difficile pour nous
que pour d'autres de devoir rénover des
institutions est ce que tu penses que
c'est aujourd'hui le moment de le faire
ici c'est le moment de le faire comme je
crois que nous sommes quelques uns à le
faire comment réussir ce défi de rénover
nos institutions cet outil de la
démocratie pour mieux la faire vivre en
restant fidèle à l'esprit de la vème
république du gaullisme et du régime
présidentiel mais en permettant à nos
concitoyens de davantage s'y retrouver
c'est une question qui est absolument
clé
si l'on prend l'exemple de l'épidémie
qui vient de se dérouler dans laquelle
nous sommes encore d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant de noter que les pays qui
s'en sont le mieux sorties sont les pays
qui ont plus fait confiance à leurs
concitoyens et où le débat démocratique
a été vigoureux il ya pour ceux qui
s'intéressent l'excellent un article à
lire je vous donne la référence revue
commentaire août 2020 par nicolas
baverez et il donne
une analyse de la vertu de la discussion
et de la dispute intellectuelle je crois
à la vertu de la dispute intellectuelle
quand je suis arrivé au parlement
européen à strasbourg j'ai été très
troublé c'est un parlement il n'y a pas
de majorité
cet affreux pour nous parce que nous
vivons avec le souvenir maudit de la
quatrième république et j'ai découvert
la vertu de la discussion et du
compromis quand personne n'a la majorité
vous êtes obligé pour voter une loi
forcément de vous accorder les uns avec
les autres bref de discuter aujourd'hui
nous sommes arrivés à une accusation du
système qui fait que tout procède du
président de la république ça ne peut
pas marcher
vous rendez compte que vous étiez chez
vous de votre poste de télévision et
vous attendiez
le jeudi soir souvent ça arrivait que le
président décide oui on va ou pas vous
confiné personnes une minute avant ne
savait ce qu'il allait dire est ce que
vous connaissez une seule organisation
humaine où l'on puisse procéder ainsi
moi je ne connais pas si nous ont ça
dans nos conseils municipaux dans nos
conseils régionaux xavier valérie si
nous ferons ça faisons ça dans nos
conseils départementaux ou cher georges
siffredi que je salue président du
département et bien ça ne peut pas
marcher fait ça de votre entreprise ça
ne peut pas marcher non plus en fait
nous devons réapprendre à faire
confiance aux autres dans le code de
déontologie médicale ya une très belle
phrase je ne trahirai jamais votre
confiance cette phrase là ça doit être
la phrase qui nous anime la vertu de la
confiance c'est la vertu démocratique
première quand le peuple n'a pas
confiance dans les gouvernés
dans les gouvernants pardon les
gouvernés lui font pas confiance à séoul
au plus fort de la crise
il y avait très peu de morts
ils n'étaient pas en train de confiner
et un journaliste a demandé
à la maire de séoul madame la maire
pourquoi ça marche et vous aurez plus de
lits de réanimation plus de masques plus
de tests et qu'est ce qu'elle répond
elle répond non chez nous ce qui marche
et la confiance les gens nous croient
quand on dit quelque chose on le fait
quand on s'est trompé on le dit et on
s'excuse là nous avons eu l'absence de
mea culpa nous avons eu absolument le
contraire je crois que nous devons
réinventer une manière et une ré
inventer une manière de faire de la
politique est une parole publique -
descendante plus partagés c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça et je reprends la
question dany tout à l'heure que la
décentralisation est évidemment un moyen
de faire revivre la démocratie parce que
c'est au niveau des centralisateur que
le débat ne peut pas être troqués nous
ne pouvons pas échapper nous les élus
locaux à nos électeurs
[Applaudissements]
merci on commence les questions avec les
micros jaune s'il vous plaît
bonjour bonjour monsieur juin merci pour
cette journée tervention romain ici je
me vois donc de l'isère élu conseiller
national de l'isère ma question c'est
par rapport aux impôts que je vais vous
la posez moi je suis chef d'entreprise
et cadres d'entreprise j'ai deux
travaillent
aujourd'hui avec mon épouse on a décidé
de vendre nos appartements parce que on
a le droit à une chose dans la classe
moyenne payer payer payer demain on aura
des enfants certainement et j'aurais
envie de leur transmettre quelque chose
forcément ma question est simple est-ce
que vous allez revenir sur ce qu'avait
fait le président nicolas sarkozy
c'est à dire un allègement des impôts de
droits de succession voire une
annulation
et qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
nous la classe moyenne on a juste un
droit c'est celui de payer et le droit
d'être
confronté à toutes ces minorités qui
veulent tout à qui on donne tout et puis
nous on est un peu les oubliés on a
droit de payer pour elle voilà merci
bravo bravo je partage comme vous cette
idée que quand on travaille toute sa vie
on a le droit de transmettre le fruit de
son travail qui a été taxé de multiples
fois de multiples fois quand vous
constituer un patrimoine vous avez été
taxés quand vous avez gagné de l'argent
vous avez été taxés quand vous avez
acheté le patrimoine quand vous l'avez
entretenu bref à toutes les étapes et
donc moi je ne souhaite pas enfin je
souhaite que chaque français chaque
française puisse transmettre son
patrimoine
que ça soit d'ailleurs un patrimoine
d'entreprise ou un patrimoine
particulier et évidemment je veux et là
je rends je rend justice à eric ciotti
qu'est le premier dans ce débat de la
primaire à l'avoir dit je crois que nous
ne pouvons pas accepter nous la droite
qui croyons à la liberté cet impôt sur
la mort donc je reviendrai sur cette
taxation scandaleuse des impôts de
succession
monsieur à la barbe ça monsieur en rouge
oui alors oui monsieur en honorant le
micro orange c'est de l' orange oui je
le rends du rouge pardon
bonjour bertrand gille rouge vient de
charente-maritime troisième
circonscription dont je suis délégué
monsieur juin vous avez été le seul à
parler de démographie en afrique en
reprenant les mots de nicolas sarkozy et
de jean louis borloo est-ce que vous
privilégiez les investissements en
afrique au détriment de l'investissement
pour les français
alors c'est vrai que dans les débats
quand on a parlé d'immigration ged une
chose très simple
c'est que moi aussi je veux des règles
pour que l'immigration ne soit pas la
france ne soit pas comme un supermarché
ou rentrer et je fais qu'un choisi de
venir et de faire ce qu'il veut la
france a des frontières et ses
frontières elles doivent être respectées
dans le cadre de notre été cela va de
soi je suis contre pas je suis favorable
par exemple à la à la disparition de
toute aide sociale non contributives à
toute personne qui entre sur le
territoire pendant les cinq prochains
première année il va de soi qu'on ne
peut pas avoir accès
à diverses allocations dès lors qu'on
n'a pas contribué à la richesse générale
d'un pays sur ces allocations non
contributives je crois d'ailleurs que
toute personne qui arrive sur le
territoire national ne peut pas avoir
accès à un logement social pendant cinq
premières années enfin vous voyez la
difficulté que nous avons à obtenir des
logements sociaux sociaux pour tous donc
ce n'est pas possible maintenant ce que
je crois aussi c'est que toutes les
mesures que nous prendrons
elles seront vaines mes amis vaine si
l'on ne s'intéresse pas à la question de
l'origine de l'immigration
le nigeria c'est ce que je dis à la
télévision aura plus d'habitants que les
états unis d'amérique dans 20 ans à
votre avis que va faire le père ou la
mère d'un enfant malade au nigeria si
cet enfant pour survivre doit prendre un
médicament qui est au nord chez nous et
pas chez lui qu'est ce qu'il va faire il
va prendre son enfant sur son dos il va
franchir à pied toute l'afrique il
franchira coûte que coûte la
méditerranée et il arrivera en france et
pourquoi il le fera parce que vous ne
feriez aussi il faut pas se raconter
d'histoires et moi je pense que nous
devons
so lu ment nous attaquer à ce problème
des infrastructures en afrique jean
louis borloo il ya travail et nadine
morano connaît parfaitement cette
question également
nous devons comprendre que le
développement des infrastructures en
afrique qui va permettre de stabiliser
les peuples africains en afrique c'est
de notre intérêt si de plus nous avons
quelques intelligence parfois nous ne
sommes pas dépourvus les européens
parfois nous sommes un peu naïf mais
parfois nous arrivons à une palette
totalement si ces travaux
d'infrastructure en plus peut être
peuvent être faits par des entreprises
européennes et françaises je rêve
extraordinaire ce serait absolument
formidable et nous gagnerions sur tous
les tableaux mais ne croyez pas un
instant que ce net en n'ayant que des
politiques chez nous que nous en
tirerons ce n'est pas vrai on peut
vouloir le croire parce que c'est
intellectuellement confortable mais
c'est faux c'est tout simplement faux
alors comment on le finance et bien au
niveau européen dans les six prochaines
années y aura 200 milliards d'euros sur
les fonds du fonds de développement
économique et régionaux ce qu'on appelle
les fédère les présidents de région le
savent qu'ils sont des fonds européens
très important pour le développement des
régions et bien moi j'assume que la
moitié de ces fonds doivent être
utilisés pour investir massivement et
construire une afrique d'infrastructures
pour faire en sorte que les africains
restent en afrique puisse y vivent se
faire soigner être éduqués nous avons
intérêt à participer à cet effort pour
limiter notre immigration et empêcher
que d'autres je pense à nos amis chinois
y met un pied et eux se chargent de
développer l'afrique et la 6e ils y
arrivent vous verrez ce sera une autre
paire de manches
le micro bleus s'il vous plaît madame
merci madame la présidente bonjour à
tous karine torossian délégué de la
troisième circonscription du val d'oise
alors philippe juvin vous vous
distinguer des autres propositions des
autres candidats qui souhaitent
notamment baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires alors vous vous n'y est
pas favorable vous l'avais dit à
plusieurs reprises or comment faire pour
renforcer nos services publics auxquels
nous tenons tant comment les rendre plus
moderne plus efficace et tout cela en
tenant compte de la dette on n'en parle
plus comme si on avait oublié les
finances la question des finances
publiques
comment faire en même temps pour
renforcer enfin pour améliorer la
situation des finances publiques
et tout cela sans supprimer de
fonctionnaires de postes de
fonctionnaires
madame vous avez raison j'assume ce que
vous êtes dire vous savez que dans la
fonction publique hospitalière les
hôpitaux publics
vous n'allez pas me croire mais je vous
le dis quand même parce que c'est la
vérité il ya autant d'équivalents temps
plein deux médecins or interne que
d'équivalents temps plein administratif
autant
autant d'administratifs que deux
médecins je pense qu'on est chez les
fous à venir peut-être que c'est
nécessaire qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'administratif pour bien faire
fonctionner un hôpital pourquoi pas vous
savez dans l'armée américaine ya un
combattant pour 9 logisticiens donc on
peut tout imaginer eh bien il se trouve
que l'année où cette donnée a été publié
en 2016 à l'ap a été republié depuis un
an 2016 est bien la même étude a été
faite par le même organisme d'état
l'adresse sur les cliniques privées et
dans les cliniques privées le ratio ces
trois médecins pour un administratif et
je vous assure qu'ils sont aussi bien
soigné évidemment les pathologies sont
plus compliquées ya des missions qui
n'ont pas accès à trois pour un un pour
un nous avons donc beaucoup de marge moi
ce que je veux je vous la sueur
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas en état
de diminuer le nombre de fonctionnaires
et je diminuerait pas en revanche je
veux qu'ils aient plus de fonctionnaires
au contact du public plus de
fonctionnaires à l'hôpital pour vous
soigner plus de fonctionnaires dans les
maisons de retraite pour donner à manger
et donner une douche un torres veut
interroger vous comment une aide
soignante qui doit donner à manger à
quelqu'un qui n'arrive pas à des plus
tire ce qui est banal pour quelqu'un qui
a une maille d'alzheimer à qu'il faut
une heure pour déjeuner comment une aide
soignant peut-elle donner à manger à 25
personnes quand elle est seule est-ce
que vous ne croyez pas que dans les
maisons de retraite médicalisées il se
passe des choses que vous préférez ne
pas savoir parce que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment de personnel c'est ça la
réalité des choses
combien de fois en tant que père de la
garenne ai-je entendu un de mes
concitoyens venir me voir en disant j'ai
appelé la police et qu'ils me répondent
qu'ils avaient pas de véhicules
disponibles et donc ils sont pas venus
combien de fois je vois un bureau de
poste qui ferment et on nous dira mais
c'est pas grave on va le rencontrer on
va le remplacer par une petite agence
municipale payé d'ailleurs par le maire
et plus par la poste bref je crois tout
simplement parce que je vois les choses
madame je les vois comme maire je les
vois comme comme médecin hospitalier je
les ai même vu comme militaires en
afghanistan où nous n'avions que deux
hélicoptères à la fois pour aller
chercher les blessés sur le champ de
bataille et transporter les soldats
c'était une sorte de paupérisation
générale et bien moi je n'en peux plus
de cette paupérisation donc je ne
baisserai pas le nombre de
fonctionnaires j'augmenterais le nombre
de fonctionnaires par redistribution et
au contact du public et par exemple à
l'hôpital c'est très simple je diviserai
par trois le nombre administratif à
l'hôpital public et ces postes en moins
je les utilise c'est pour ça que je ne
baisse pas le nombre global de
fonctionnaires
avec un pour payer des gens qui sont au
contact des patients et enfin pour
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
infirmières et des aides soignants qui
aujourd'hui n'en peuvent plus sont
crevés sont usés et gags des clopinettes
eh bien je tirerai les conséquences
quant à l'hôpital il ya 20% des postes
qui ne sont pas pourvus et bien la masse
salariale qui n'est pas utilisé elle
sera dur distribués à ceux qui font deux
ou trois fois plus de travail c'est
comme ça que je vois les choses oui donc
je re
je ferai en sorte que les services
publics soient de nouveau une valeur de
la droite merci le micro rouge à vous
monsieur il est rouge ou orange mais je
ne suis pas écoute de loin franchement
c'est pas facile non monsieur l'orangé
rouge voilà à les y va je m'appelle
radouane le responsable départemental
des jeunes républicains du territoire de
belfort je voulais vous poser une
question sur la sécurité certaines nos
quartiers sont devenus de véritables
ghettos bien sûr la police les pompiers
se font caillasser il n'ya plus d'ordre
dans ces quartiers quand les pompiers la
police se font caillasser c'est la
république entière qui se fait attaquer
ça ne l'accepteront jamais vous avez
oppositions formulées vous à cet égard
vous avez absolument raison monsieur est
ce que certains d'entre vous ici ont vu
le film back nord
ceux qui l'ont pas vu alésien les trois
premiers quarts d'heure il sauve qu'à la
bac nord à marseille
macha méril sauf qu'un des policiers est
un ancien de la bac de la
garenne-colombes donc voyez on a des
nous avons des relations
et il m'explique que c'est ce qu'ils
vivent au quotidien et je veux bien les
croire
qu'est ce que je ferais bien c'est assez
simple la philosophie de faire en sorte
que quelqu'un qui commet une infraction
sache que systématiquement il sera
poursuivi dans ma commune j'ai de
multiples exemples de voyous
qui sont mineurs
et que la police à trappes et puis on
leur fait laboral ça s'appelle rappel à
la loi une fois deux fois dix fois
quinze fois ça ne sert à rien moi je
verrais les choses différemment premier
rappel à loi 100 euros damende notion de
ce deuxième rappel à la loi 200 euros
damende 10e rappel à la loi mille euros
damende le rodéo je confisque le scooter
ou la moto le mariage qui bloque toute
la rue je confie ce que les voitures il
faut que nous ayons une vision
opérationnelle et agile des choses c'est
ainsi que nous avions la même manière la
prison madame belloubet
digne successeur de madame taubira
la bien nommée oui je vois que tu
oublieras ça marche toujours quelques
années plus tard nous avons la mémoire
à supprimer les petites peines de prison
les petites peines voyez les pagnes de
deux jours de trois jours de quatre
jours et moi je les rétablir est ces
petites peines c'est pas ça qui va faire
en sorte que les prisons sont encombrées
si vous restez trois jours ça ne
comprends rien du tout mais vous avez vu
la tête d'un adolescent quand voulu
supprimer son portable durant une
demi-heure il fait une crise d'épilepsie
et bien là quand il l'aura eu supprimés
pendant une semaine je peux vous assurer
que la prochaine fois il fera en sorte
de ne pas aller en prison parce que
c'est très désagréable de ne pas avoir
de portable pendant une semaine voilà
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'il faut agir
alors évidemment il faut augmenter le
nombre de places de prison et évidemment
je le ferai mais vous comprenez ça à
prendre dix ans souffre ou dix ans pour
faire une passe de prison fait pas
d'illusions donc c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut que nous ayons des des
actions immédiates nous serons jugés
dans les six mois c'est bien cela qu'il
faut comprendre jean françois copé
m'avait expliqué que quand il avait été
élu maire de meaux il n'avait pas
d'argent mots étaient pas en très bon
état et donc il avait voulu dans le
premier mois montré qu'il tenait sa
ville et il avait même et il dit repos
europe 1 toute sa vie il m'a dit ça
coûte pas cher mais en revanche en un
mois tous les gens avaient vu que
j'étais là bas nous c'est pareil on va
repeindre la france on va la repeindre
avec des mesures comme ça
mais on poursuit avec le micro jaune
merci beaucoup yannick boillod de la
fédération 35 en bretagne dont j'ai été
en laboratoires hospitaliers de 2003
2016 pour partir ensuite créé mon
entreprise pourquoi je suis parti parce
que nous avons malheureusement été deux
personnes sur 15 a failli faire un
burn-out
paradoxale avec un lieu destiné à nous
soigner peut devenir aussi un lieu de
souffrance au travail malheureusement
quelle est votre vision des 35 heures à
l'hôpital et que pensez-vous des agences
régionales de santé faut-il et supprimer
les réformer merci beaucoup
ce que vous décrivez monsieur
est évidemment la vérité et ça s'est
aggravé
ceux qui sont intéressés par la question
je les invite à aller chercher sur
internet le rapport du conseil
scientifique
du 5 octobre dernier qui décrit l'état
dans lequel sont les soignants en france
actuellement deux tiers des soignants
qui travaillent dans les réanimations
sont en situation d'accepter ou
dépression deux tiers moi dans mon
service je les infirmières que tu étais
en burn out j'ai eu des démissions j'ai
désormais des médecins qui ne veulent
plus travailler plein temps vous
n'imaginez pas mesdames et messieurs si
vous n'y êtes pas l'état de
dégradation
extrême de notre système de santé dont
on disait il ya quelques années qu'il
était le meilleur du monde voyez comme
les choses vont vite
donc oui je pense que c'est un sujet
d'une très grande importance est
extrêmement préoccupant donc la santé
je ferai en sorte qu'elle soit gérée
d'une manière totalement différente de
la manière dont elle est gérée
aujourd'hui je des centraliserait la
santé je confierais la totalité de la
santé les agences régionales de santé y
compris l'ondam qui sera régionalisée
aux régions je veux faire confiance aux
élus locaux parce que je sais une chose
c'est que les présidents de région quand
ils s'appuient sur les présidents de
départements et les maires ils savent la
réalité du terrain ils s'adapteront de
choses donc je veux
bouleverser le système de santé en la
matière deuxièmement je veux faire de la
santé autre chose je créerai un
ministère n'ont pas de la santé ça
existe déjà mais un ministère dé santé
parce que évidemment la santé c'est la
médecine de ville évidemment la santé
c'est l'hôpital évidemment sur les
maisons de retraite mais la santé c'est
aussi l'air que vous respirez
l'alimentation vous mangez la santé
c'est aussi la santé au travail c'est la
santé environnementale c'est la santé
animale tout ça c'est une santé globale
partout dans le monde les gouvernements
ont désormais cette approche globale la
santé c'est de la recherche essai de
l'enrichissement du pays
en allemagne 0 5% du pib vous rendez
compte c'est énorme et du simplement à
l'invention de leurs vaccins
le fameux vaccin de pfizer dont vous
avez tous entendu parler 0,5 pour cent
du pib nous en france on a une des
hôpitaux qui tombe des maisons de
retraite
donc sur lesquels il ya beaucoup de
choses à dire et on a plus de 25 et plus
de brevets nous disparaissons et nous
devons non des objets de l'action
politique mondiale ça je n'en veut plus
et la santé aura son rôle à jouer
bien merci madame le microbe le m
l'adjointe à la culture
merci madame la présidente bonsoir
monsieur marie laurence m maire adjoint
en charge de la culture seconde
circonscription de l'aisne
ma question porte tout naturellement sur
le domaine de la culture
aujourd'hui la culture heureux signifie
inéquité de territoires et secteurs
totalement oubliés notamment le domaine
de la de la musique si vous n'avez pas
un président de région à l'ecoute
soucieux de rétablir un certain
équilibre et dont les équipes viennent à
notre rencontre sur le terrain que
faites vous enfin je souhaiterais
remercier les représentants du sénat qui
nous ont sollicités
au titre du plan de relance culture nous
pauvres élus locaux très souvent oublié
c'est la première fois que j'ai été
solide étaient donc à ce titre merci le
plan de relance culture concerne
essentiellement les compagnies les
compagnies en résidence c'est très bien
mais pour qu'elle soit en résidence il
faut qu'il y ait des collectivités qui
les accueillent et il ne faut pas
éternellement considéré les
collectivités comme les américains qui
vont supplée à tous quelle vision
donnerez-vous à la culture et quelle est
votre position pour rapprocher les élus
locaux des besoins en donc avec l'état
bien évidemment merci
[Applaudissements]
primo levi expliqué qu'une des
caractéristiques de l'enfance c'est
comme les enfants n'avaient pas
d'expérience personnelle
par définition ce sont des enfants il
avait tendance à voir le monde en blanc
et en noir en gentil en mauvais bref
qu'il n'avait pas conscience de la
complexité des choses et du monde la
culture elle permet justement à des
enfants puis à des jeunes puis à des
adultes
d'accumuler les expériences et d'avoir
mieux conscience de la config complexité
des choses
la culture est indispensable à la
formation de ce qu'on appelait au xviie
siècle l'honnête homme est aujourd'hui
de ce qu'on a de ce qu'on devrait
appeler aujourd'hui un citoyen éclairé
donc la culture fait partie intégrante
d'un programme politique au sens grec du
terme comme on l'aurait la réanimer et
bien faire en sorte que chacun ait accès
aujourd'hui on baptise culture tout et
n'importe quoi moi je crois à la
nécessité de renforcer l'enseignement
culturel à l'école tout commence par là
comment s'ouvrir aux oeuvres de l'esprit
comment mieux aimer la france si ce
n'est
s'immerger dans ses oeuvres de l'esprit
que ce soit la littérature ou la
sculpture ou la musique où l'expression
artistique dans toutes ses formes oui
donc il n'y a pas de citoyens éclairés
sont culture je ferai en sorte que cette
culture retrouve dans l'école de la
république toutes ses lettres de
noblesse on a trop souvent considéré que
la culture devait passer après le reste
et on a trop souvent considéré que tous
les arts se valaient je ne crois pas je
pense que les harkis ont façonné le pays
la france son histoire votre modèle de
civilisation sur les arts qu'il faut
tirer vers le haut et montrer aux jeunes
enfants
et enfin dernière question
vous avez la parole merci
docteur bonjour
bonjour docteur
grégory cherchent à monsieur merci
grégory buisson conseiller national
départementale de l'isère et puis ancien
conseiller municipal de gonzague la
capitale delannoy une question tout
brève médecine est ce que vous êtes pour
le vaccin obligatoire pour tous tout
simplement à question qui personne je
pense à penser pour l'instant j'attends
des réponses mais monsieur vous avez
raison mais parce qu'en fait ce n'est
pas une question médicale ça aurait été
une question médicale je vous aurais
répondu aussi et c'est une question qui
te dépasse de médecine parce que tous
les samedis on est embêté par des
et là sociaux qui viennent nous embêter
voilà jeudi le mot cas sociaux j'ai le
droit si avec cela monsieur voilà non
samedi serait plus calme ouais on va on
peut s'en passer je pense mais votre
question est très pertinente
merci tout d'abord
qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté puisque
vous poser aussi la question aux
médecins aujourd'hui l'épidémie n'est
pas terminée il s'en faut de beaucoup il
s'en faut de beaucoup et quand on vous
dit ça remonte on vous donne un nombre
de cas je vous rappelle quand même
content est moi aujourd'hui comme tester
avant donc
deuxièmement
soyez conscients d'une chose c'est que
notre système de santé dont je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure est un système de
santé qui est à l'os
s'il y avait le moindre début de
commencement de ce qui nous est arrivé
en mars 2020 ne pourrions pas tenir
nous ne sommes pas aujourd'hui en
capacité nous le système de santé de
prendre en charge les hommes et les
femmes de france si demain il ya une
épidémie de grippe un peu sévère avec
une augmenter d hospitalisation nous ne
pouvons pas non plus je veux que vous
compreniez que la situation est d'une
gravité extrême
face à cela qu avons-nous comme
possibilités d'action évidemment les
fameuses mesures barrières qui ont été
très bien respectée par monsieur castex
où les bus et quelques jours
et puis évidemment la question de la
vaccination le vaccin
permet de diminuer la fréquence pas de
la de
l'empêcher absolument ya aucun
médicament qui empêche rien absolument
mais qui diminue considérablement le
risque de faire une forme grave donc
c'est un outil dont il ne faut pas se
passer la difficulté de ce vaccin c'est
que au bout de quelques mois
probablement six mois il est moins
efficace moi je suis favorable à
l'ouverture immédiate du vaccin à tous
ceux qui ont été vaccinés il ya plus de
six mois quel que soit leur âge parce
que je veux sauver les fêtes de noël je
faire en sorte que le pays ne se
retrouve pas dans une situation
impossible où on ne peut plus soigner
ceux qui n'ont pas le coc vide parce que
c'est ça la situation nous ne soyons pas
les autres parce que nous sommes
submergés par le cos vide rendez vous
compte qu'il y aura probablement
quelques milliers de morts deux morts
dans les années qui viennent d'un
certain nombre de cancers qui n'ont pas
été diagnostiquée à temps qui n'ont pas
été traités à temps parce que nous avons
un système qui est trop petit comprenez
cela alors maintenant vous me demandez
faut-il qu'elle soit obligatoire eh bien
je ne crois pas et je vous réponde
pourquoi c'est parce que l'état s'abîme
monsieur à rendre à édicter des règles
qu'il n'est pas capable de faire
respecter
moi je ne sais pas comment faire en
sorte de m'assurer que tout le monde est
bien vacciné je ne sais pas vous y
oblige et déjà cher monsieur si nous
arrivions à vacciner correctement avec
les deux premières doses la totalité de
la population française ça serait déjà
bien vous savez que les français âgé de
85 ans qui sont essentiellement des
françaises mesdames les français âgé de
85 ans sont moins vacciner que les
français âgé de 45 ans aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes pas allés jusqu'au bout
de la première étape donc allons
jusqu'au bout de la première étape
décrétons que la troisième dose est
ouverte à tous ceux qui veulent se
vacciner après six mois et après nous
nous poserons nous sommes
extraordinaires en france nous nous
créons des débats
complexes complexe que parfois nous ne
savons pas résoudre en l'occurrence
faire respecter une obligation de
vaccination je ne sais pas le faire en
tout cas chez l'adulte chez l'enfant
j'ai quelques idées mais celle du tenant
et nous ne voyons pas qu'en fait nous ne
sommes pas parfaits sur le reste des
débats je me demande d'ailleurs si
parfois ce n'est pas volontaire et si
parfois le gouvernement n'est pas
content de lancer comme ça des débats
dont il sait qu'il n'ya pas de réponse
ça lui évite de répondre à ces
imperfections sur ce qu'il n'a pas fait
bien et dieu sait qu'ils n'ont pas fait
bien les choses voilà donc ma réponse
sur monsieur
eq si un mot de conclusion philippe
merci ma chère amie et bien écoutez
votre conclusion il pourrait être de
vous dire que c'est vrai je n'ai pas le
parcours identique à mes concurrents
comme
l'ex point l'express l'expression
consacrée
je crois que néanmoins la droite tire un
premier bénéfice considérable de cette
élection mon cher christian et c'est
grâce à toi c'est que de nouveaux la
droite existe
deux nouveaux vous vous dites oui nous
pouvons y arriver
moi je crois ont la nécessité d'une
équipe nous sommes divers nous avons des
parcours divers nous avons des approches
diverses on a vu nos approches divers
sur les services publics on a vu nos
approches diverses sur des questions
internationales nous avons des visions
diverses des choses mais c'est ça qui
fait la richesse d'autres familles
politiques nous ne sommes pas aux
républicains une caserne où tout le
monde marche en marche du même pas ce
n'est pas ça l'est républicain les
républicains c'est une famille plurielle
où les hommes et les femmes acceptent de
discuter ensemble de sujets sur lesquels
il se dit faire pourquoi parce qu'ils
savent que ce qui les rapproche et de
toute façon plus important que ce qui
les sépare c'est ça la droite
républicaine ce sera la droite des
républicains
comme moi vous êtes la droite qui aiment
le travail vous êtes la droite qui
croient à ce travail vous êtes la droite
qui croient aux services publics d'être
la droite qui croient aux libertés vous
êtes la droite qui croient que la france
plusieurs fois dans son histoire à
éclairer le monde et moi je veux que ce
soit toujours le cas je que la france ne
soit pas un objet dans le monde actuel
qui se voient imposer des diktats de
l'extérieur parce qu'elle veut de devenu
faible je crois en cette france qui
fasse en sorte que quand il y à des
questions complexes on se tourne vers
elle c'est toujours extraordinaire de
penser que quand vous êtes à l'étranger
et que vous n'êtes que vous dites que
vous êtes français on vous regarde
toujours différemment
parce que nous la france nous avons une
parole particulière bien supérieur au
poids réel de notre économie point
supérieur au poids réel de notre
démographie parce que nous sommes tout
simplement la france alors moi je n'ai
qu'un voeu à formuler c'est que cette
france que nous aimons que cette france
pour laquelle vous avez tant donné cette
france pour laquelle vos pairs et vos
grands parents ont parfois donné leur
vie et leur liberté et bien cette france
nous puissions la transmettre à nos
enfants et nos petits enfants en leur
disant vous êtes désormais les gardiens
de cette vieille histoire c'est à vous
de jouer mais pour ça cette france nous
devons la réanimer vive la république
vive la france
[Applaudissements]